JEN PERSON: Welcome to
"Who's [? There?", ?]
A show about Cloud Identity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last episode of
"Who's [? There?", ?]
I talked about why Identity
Platform is awesome,
and how to enable it
in your GCP project.
Today I'm showing you how to
integrate Identity Platform
into your Android app in Java.
If you haven't enabled
Identity Platform yet,
I recommend you check out the
last episode of "Who's There?"
before proceeding.
You also need an Android app.
In Android Studio, start
with an existing app,
or create a new one.
And if Android doesn't
happen to be your jam,
check out the Getting Started
videos for iOS and web,
both linked below.
All right, with all the
prerequisites out of the way,
let's get started.
In the Cloud console
for my project,
I selected the
Identity Platform tab.
I previously had an email
and password authentication,
so if you haven't yet,
click Add a Provider
and select Email Password.
There are lots of other
providers to explore,
but today, I'm just going
to stick with this one.
On the Providers
page, you see a link
in the upper-right for
Application Setup Details.
This pops up a window with brief
getting started information.
When I click the
Android tab, I see
to get started with
Android, you'll
need to register and add
Firebase configuration
to your app.
Learn More.
I click Get Started with
Firebase, which takes me
to an entirely new console.
Some of the information is
the same as the Cloud Console,
like project name
and ID, but then
there are all
these new tabs down
the side that say Develop,
Quality, Analytics, and Grow--
and a big pop-up in the middle
asking about data sharing.
If you've used Firebase before,
this probably looks familiar,
but it's entirely possible
you've never even heard
of Firebase, let alone used it.
So let's talk about
what's going on here.
Firebase is a suite of products
to help you build your app
and grow your user base.
It includes SDKs for
Objective-C and Swift
for iOS, Java and Kotlin for
Android, JavaScript for web,
as well as several web
frameworks like Angular.
There are game-specific SDKs for
Unity in C++, and so much more.
I can make a whole series
of videos just on Firebase,
but fortunately, the Firebase
team has already done that.
If you're interested
in finding out more,
check out the documentation in
the Firebase YouTube channel,
both linked below.
So in many ways, Firebase
is the perfect complement
to Google Cloud.
Very broadly speaking,
Google Cloud products
focus on server-side
solutions like App Engine,
Compute Engine, Cloud
Functions, Kubernetes Engine,
and Cloud Run.
And Firebase products focus
on client-side solutions
like authentication,
cloud messaging,
cloud storage for
Firebase, and so on.
And I admit that
it's challenging
to pin down the relationship
between Google Cloud
and Firebase.
So for my oversimplified
explanation
is that Firebase is a way
to access some Google Cloud
Platform products from
a client application.
Specifically, for
Identity Platform,
this explanation works well.
The Firebase Auth
SDKs enable you
to access Identity
Platform functionality
from your client app.
With that in mind, let's head
back to that Firebase Console.
The Firebase Console
automatically
opened to our project.
Notice this UI indicates
that Quick Start is already
a Firebase project.
When adding Identity Platform
to a Google Cloud project,
a Firebase project is
automatically created.
First, let's deal
with this pop-up.
It's up to you whether
you want to check off
to use the default settings
for Google Analytics Data,
or just to select Do This Later.
Some Firebase products depend
on analytics, like A/B testing,
so if you decide to
incorporate other features,
you'll probably
want to enable this.
Again, it's entirely up to you.
When you click on
the Project Settings,
notice that the settings are
identical to the Cloud Quick
Start project.
Firebase has basically
added some more details
and functionality to
the Cloud project,
similar to when
you enable an API
or add software from
the marketplace.
Since you want to add Identity
Platform to an Android app,
select Add App, Android.
This gives you a window with
a series of steps to follow.
Now, keep in mind when you
pick the Android package name,
it must match the package
name of your Android app.
The app nickname is
totally up to you.
You can leave it
blank if you prefer.
I don't provide the
SHA-1 certificate,
since I'm not using any of
the products for which it
is required.
But if you plan on implementing
Google Sign In or Phone Number
Sign [? In and ?] [? Auth, ?]
feel free to add the SHA-1 here
before creating [? an app. ?]
You can also add it later.
Now you are prompted to download
a Google Services JSON file.
This file informs your Android
app about the Firebase app
so you can interface
with Firebase products.
Once downloaded, add this
to your Android project.
Click Next in the console, and
it gives you the next step.
Add the gradle dependencies
required to use Firebase.
In addition to the
gradle files required
to build a Firebase
app, you also
need specific gradle file
to use Firebase Auth.
Add the following project level
and app level dependencies.
You can see them here.
In your app in Android
Studio, declare
an instance of Firebase Auth.
OK, now you can use
the Firebase Auth
SDK to sign up, log
in, log out, and get
user info about an
Identity Platform user.
Identity Platform
gives you access
to many different
log in providers,
including federated identity
providers like Google,
Facebook, and Twitter.
You can enable several
log in methods for an app,
allowing your users
to authenticate
the way that they prefer.
Some log in methods may
require additional steps,
which are listed
in the console when
you enable that log in method.
See the documentation
below for information
on how to implement
other log in providers.
For now, let's get back to
implementing email and password
log in.
In the Cloud Console,
create a fake user
with a test email
and a test password.
Of course, you can create
a new user from the client,
but this is a good
way to get your app up
and running quickly.
See how to create a
user in your Android
app following the link below.
In onStart, call a
function called logIn.
This function calls the
Firebase Auth method sign
in with email and
password, passing
the email and password you
created in the Cloud Console.
When the sign in
function completes,
the onComplete
listener is called,
passing the Auth result task.
If the task is successful,
then you are signed in.
I've added a log
[? and toast ?] to reflect this.
If the sign in fails, I
display this as well--
just for our
reference right now.
So it's clear that my example
thus far is not a complete auth
solution.
You need a way for users
to create accounts, handle
password resets, and log out.
Each of these functions needs
some UI development as well.
If you prefer, you can write
all this functionality yourself
using the Firebase
guides as reference.
But you also have the option
to use the Firebase Auth UI
module.
This open source UI was created
by Auth specialists at Google.
It includes all
the views you would
need to implement
account creation,
log in, log out, and
password reset functionality.
You can incorporate Auth UI
in just a few lines of code.
Personally, whenever
I start a new project,
I use Firebase UI so I can focus
on the key features of my app,
while still protecting data
through authentication.
But whether you make your
own UI or use Firebase UI,
you will very likely need
to know the auth status
before performing
any app actions.
For example, you want to check
if there is a user logged in
before writing to a database.
That's where getting the
current user comes into play.
Let's look at how to
implement that functionality.
To get the currently
signed-in user,
call getCurrentUser on your
Firebase Auth instance.
You may have noticed that this
function was already called
in the onSuccess listener.
If the appearance of
your UI depends upon
whether there is a current user,
you can call getCurrentUser
in onStart.
I put the code to log out in
this separate function called
logOut.
I'm going to call this
function at the end
of the onSuccess listener if
the log in was successful.
Of course, it's unusual to log
in only to log out immediately,
but this is purely for
the sake of example,
so you can see the
log out function run.
OK, I build and run the
app, and the console
logs show that the user has
logged in, and then logged out.
Congratulations.
You just added Identity
Platform to an Android app.
Ready to see what else
Identity Platform can do?
Check out the Firebase Auth
Android guides, Auth Quick
Start Code, and Firebase
YouTube channel,
and subscribe to the Google
Cloud Platform channel
so you can be the first to
know about new videos in the
"Who's There?" series.
Thanks for watching, and I'll
see you on a future episode.